step back up here brother right there oh
my god
oh my god god
cries come on
thank you thank you oh my god
you're not here just to tell me hi
as drew pearson getting the word from
david baker and the ultra distinctive
voice of jerry jones in the background
that had to be jerry jones when you got
the news here he is drew pearson one of
the new members of the hall of fame drew
congratulations welcome back to the show
yeah thank you thanks for having me and
uh having me as a hall of famer feels
pretty good
let's set that stage let's let people
understand that moment when you find out
like did you get lured somewhere under
false pretenses was this like a surprise
party type of a thing how did you get to
the point where
that that that gigantic human name david
baker shows up with the news
well you said it right first i got lured
into it and uh i got a letter from rich
daryl of the pr guy from the cowboys uh
addressed to roger and i uh re
requesting a me
at the sweet 25th at 2 p.m and so we
both confirmed went over there roger and
i kind of pulled it in the parking lot
at the same time
and he didn't give me any indication
what might be going on i'm a little
upset with my quarterback uh for that
but we went inside and met rich and uh
went into the uh
room next to the uh lobby and jerry was
sitting there waiting we sat down and
talked for a little bit and i didn't
know what what i was doing there because
they were talking mostly about real
estate which they said in a letter that
it might have something to do with that
that's why i thought it was so long
logical that rob would be included
because he's involved in some ventures
with mr jones so anyway we're they're
talking and all of a sudden
i heard that knock on the door and mr
jones said drew go answer the door i
went and answered the door and then that
door well with mr david baker and you
know he can fill up a door well and he
filled it up and he came in with the
camera crew to hunt behind him
and i kind of had a feeling i knew then
what it
was all about and uh that's when the
emotions started to flow then i looked
on the other side of the room roger and
jerry over there grinning you know like
they ate the canary or something like
that and
they got me good but that's a good
could get and uh i appreciate them
taking the time to do it that way
you broke up a little bit there as you
were explaining when it was but you
mentioned to us off the air it was
january 25th which was a couple of weeks
before it became official
how hard drew
to keep that secret for nearly two weeks
yeah i'd rather play a game of nfl
fell football even against milt month
than to try to hold that in for two
weeks almost it was very difficult you
know my mouth when he told me my mouth
was like this
so it's about ready to burst with uh
wanting to tell somebody you know so i
had to tell my my kids i told them and i
made them swear to secrecy i told my
oldest sister
[Music]
my only hair swear to secrecy and i told
a few uh uh my teammates
but that was it and it was hard to keep
because i kept getting a request for
interviews and uh and in the interviews
of course they're asking me if i know
and you know i'm not the guy that wants
to lie or anything to anybody but i kind
of just danced around it as best i could
to try to make their article uh appear
like you know i didn't know or
it was going it was anticipating the
anticipation was still there uh but it
was hard to keep in no doubt and all the
guys did it you know it was a remarkable
how it really never leaked out to social
media or or the media period and that's
a tribute to all the guys and that's the
kind of class we have you know guys with
a lot of character when you tell them to
do something they do it
drew you came so close in january of
2019 on that centennial class when your
former teammate club paris got in and
jimmy johnson got in on that class too
we saw your disappointment and your
anger at not getting in at that point
now full circle a year from
then you get in again
um two years later i guess it was
did that make this more special just the
fact that you thought you were going to
get it a couple years ago and didn't
well you know what made it special is i
didn't have to wait that long after that
disappointment you know i wasn't angry i
was just disappointed i would nag i'm
not i would never be angry at the pro
football hall of fame i have too much
respect for that but i was disappointed
it did break my heart because i first
time i've ever been a finalist i thought
that would be my way to get in and maybe
the only way so it was a big
disappointment but guys i only had to
wait eight months you know here comes
august you know i'm all anticipating
that to happen and it didn't happen i
had a
everybody in my house before
anticipating as well and it didn't
happen then eight months later in august
i'm not doing yard work on work and
and i get a cough
a text message from rick gosselin saying
answer your phone when when it rings and
then when it rang it was mr david baker
telling me i was the senior not the lone
senior nominee for the class of 2021. so
i didn't have to uh worry or wait that
long for the
what i thought was a disappointment get
corrected uh with the announcement that
mr baker made
you're you were first team all decade on
the 1970s all decade team normally
that's a rubber stamp to get right into
the hall of fame
33 years is a long time to wait drew why
do you think it took so long for you to
get in as a first-team all-decade player
you know i'm not sure i've never had
uh gotten any answers or any uh
explanation for that uh i just feel like
it's i'm just like one of the other guys
especially when you're getting the
senior cat or you sometimes you get lost
in a shuffle and a lot of guys uh are
worthy of that and that's in your
category but just get lost in the show
and now guess what the new rule with one
senior coming in a year that log jab or
that center category or getting into
that door is going to be even greater
and tougher to get through so you know i
think it had something to do with that
but when i found out that i was all
decade harvey martin a second team all
decades we saw
but we talked and that would be our end
to the pro football hall of fame and we
just wanted to compound on that and try
to add to you know
what we could do on the field to add to
that to make sure to guarantee that to
make sure that would happen
but it didn't happen and there's nothing
you can do about it i can't run any more
pass routes catch any more balls i'd
like to at these prices that they're
paying nowadays but uh they don't want
any 70-year-old wide receivers out there
[Music]
but you know you know it is what it is
and that's part that's part of my legacy
that's part of what it's all about
faster the whole thing
you've got the one super bowl ring from
the 77th season the cowboys were in two
other super bowl games during your
career i feel like what happened with
the 70s was the steelers had those four
wins and they hogged up so many of the
bronze busts with their guys it made it
harder for other guys to get in
yeah i heard that and a lot of steelers
did get in and they said if we had
beacon steelers in those super bowls
that you know we'd have more cowboys in
a pro football hall of fame but you know
come on give me a
break you know i played the seasons uh
made the playoffs ten of those eleven
seasons i don't play ten player
nurses played in nfc championship games
they were mostly all in the uh 70s ended
up playing three super bowls all in the
70s so you know we had success and we
had individuals that definitely
warranted hall of fame recognition
that's why we had some guys on it going
to the hall of fame you know roger
staubach rayfield wright tony dorsett
you know just to name a few mel renfrow
just to name a few so you know we had to
qualify the athletes just like they did
and you know you can't judge
uh
one group of people on somebody else's
success and then the other group you
know you don't judge them on all success
you know there's a lot of guys in a pro
football hall of fame not saying they're
not hall of famers but there's some guys
in the pro football hey hall of fame
never played in the super bowl never
played in championship games maybe some
never even played in the playoff game
but they lumped us like that because of
that time in the 70s and uh the steelers
were so great they were a great team
that's why they beat us they that's the
only way
but it could be just by being a great
team but they were so great that they
lumped us with them and they said well
you can't beat them so they should have
more guys into the pro football hall of
fame i you know that's just me thinking
i don't know if that's their logic or
anything like that but you know that's
just the way it appears sometimes
one of the most fun aspects of getting
into the hall of fame has to be the bust
and the creation of the bust and sitting
for that have you heard from anyone yet
about that process and have you given
any thought to the facial expression
you're going to go with
oh yeah i've gotten measured already we
got measured last saturday while we were
at the super bowl and that was a pretty
cool experience you know they measure
everything they measure your lips your
eyebrows your nose
how long your ears are and all that kind
of stuff then
i told the guy who's from texas i forgot
his name but he's from texas he does
these every year
and i told him you know
you got to do my bus with row don't put
me in there like this okay nobody would
recognize me when you put me in that
afro i had back in the day
[Laughter]
yeah that's true pierce that was one of
my signature trademarks my afro you know
back in the day so my bus will have
have an afro on it
and uh you know that's one of the
highlights of the weekend you know
sitting down there uh while you're
getting measured for your bus you're
thinking wow how cool is this you know
you this is being a this is being
measured for a bus for the pro football
hall of fame and you got peyton manning
over there you got charles wood tonight
hitting their turn to get their bus uh
uh measured so it was a pretty cool
experience going through that bus
measurement
have you decided on your presenter yet
drew i know you have a lot of choices
for that
yeah you're right uh charlene i got a
lot of choices i haven't decided yet uh
i know if they were here with us would
be
their uh coach tommy or my good friend
roommate for 11 seasons with the cowboys
we came in the league together we
retired together
that's harvey martin but uh god rest
their souls unfortunately they're not
with us so now he goes to what i call
the next level uh and of course roger
staubach my quarterbacks involved in
that mix and then i got three beautiful
kids tori brittany and jared you know
they would do a tremendous job
presenting their dad and then you know
guys i grew up with uh three brothers
and three sisters and i got one older
sister left and she would do a great job
presenting her brother
as well so i haven't signed it yet but
those are the three in the mix three
scenarios in the mix
what current receiver drew most
resembles your playing style from back
then we know about the drew zone of you
going across the middle
uh none
nobody goes
no
nobody goes over it anymore
that's awesome but you know i like if
there's anybody
yeah if there's anybody you want to
compare me to is larry fitzgerald you
know not so much our styles or anything
but uh anything like that but being a
consummate pro i always start out with
the consummate troll always there for my
team and there's no question larry
fitzgerald's the consummate pro
uh you see it the way he acts not just
on the field but what he means to that
team that organization and to those
young players so if any if you want to
compare me to any receiver today you
know compare me to larry fitzgerald
because i got a lot of respect for him
and what he's done in his career what he
continues to do i don't even think he's
announced his retirement yet i guess
he's expected to play another season so
i got a lot of if you want to compare me
to anybody compare me to miss
some larry fitzgerald
hey drew we've had you on here before we
had some fun about one of your biggest
career highlights a certain catch that
you made in minnesota in the playoffs in
1975.
there's another play that caught my
attention today though the old time
football account tweeted out the tony
dorsett 99 and a half yard touchdown run
when the cowboys had 10 guys on the
field early 1983 and there's drew
pearson busting his butt 65 yards down
the field with the lunging block that
popped the thing open for dorsett what a
hustle play that was
yeah it was you know and it didn't start
out that way uh mike because we had 10
men on the field and you know we we knew
that hey i said this play is not going
to go anywhere and you know so we ran
into snap anyway because time was
running out it was just a straight hand
off to tony dorsett and i just came
jogging off the line because i'm
thinking about heading to the bench and
now we're going to punt the football out
to that play tony burst through there
and i said oh lord i better get on my
horse and i took off and
tried to lead that interference for tony
but you know tony had so many
runs where he broke out into late
daylight and out in the open
like that you know kind of knew how i
would handle those blocks downfield and
it was always a bump bump and then throw
and he read that and when i threw that's
when he went around me so that
combination of he and i playing together
since 1977 and him having so many uh
long distance run
funds uh helped us in that situation
i also knew after he scored touchdown i
better hustle down to be the first one
to graduate because that's going to be
in a record book that's going to be in a
hall of fame and i figured that might be
my only way to get into pro football of
fame
when i spot you congratulating him in
the end zone so
yeah i was the first one down there
that plays in the hall of fame dorsett's
in the hall of fame drew pearson's going
to be in the hall of fame and for
anybody out there who doesn't remember
what drew looked like in the 70s if
you're younger and you've just
discovered football recently there it is
that's what the bust is going to look
like there's drew with the afro so hey
drew congratulations and that was long
overdue we're very happy for you and we
look forward to the day when we get to
see the bust see the jacket and hear
what you have to say on your way into
the hall of fame
well thank you very much appreciate you
guys having me and uh charlene thank you
so much for your support and i
appreciate you so much
congratulations this is pierson the
original number 88
hall of famer
2021. wow so nice to say that thank you
guys god bless all right congratulations
there he is drew pearson
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports